[Music]
what came first
illegal immigration or the wall the u.s
mexico border
is the most militarized border in the
world with the exception of the korean
dmz
there are over 700 miles of fencing
patrolled by 20 000 border patrol agents
each year american taxpayers spend over
4.8 billion dollars on border patrol
and another 8.4 billion on immigrations
and custom enforcement
is our southern border really worth all
the money and taxes we're pouring into
it
hello i'm dr douglas massey i'm a
professor of sociology and public
affairs at princeton university
i've been the director of the mexican
migration project since 1982.
i've been collecting real-time data on
what's going on at the border
and none of the conclusions i've reached
to my knowledge have ever been
challenged by anyone
what many americans might not realize is
just how new
all of this border security is in the
early years of our republic
there was no firm borderline only a
fuzzy western frontier
as the frontier pushed westward the
border between america
and its neighbors continued to be
blurred when the southern border
was finalized in the mid-1800s it was
still soft and porous
an invisible line on a map that ran
through the middle of towns
and even houses in the early 1900s labor
shortages led many american farmers to
begin recruiting field workers from
mexico
the work was seasonal though with
workers coming from mexico for the
planting and harvest
and then returning to mexico for the
off-seasons
because they only stayed for the harvest
mexican workers
were not considered immigrants and
weren't included in early immigration
laws
that put quotas on other nations the u.s
border patrol was established in 1924
not to prevent the entry of mexicans but
to catch
europeans who are trying to get around
the quotas at ellis island
during the second world war the us
government actually encouraged
migration through a temporary worker
program the bracero program was created
in 1942
and steadily expanded after the war
ended by the late 1950s it was
recruiting around 450
000 mexicans per year for temporary
labor in the united states
everything changed in 1965 when the
bracero program was ended
and numerical limits were put on mexican
immigration
for the first time almost overnight
mexico went from having access to around
half a million legal visas
to less than 20 000 permanent resident
visas and no work visas
but the demand for agricultural labor
didn't go away in what was now
unauthorized or illegal migration rose
to fill the gap left by the end of the
recero program
border apprehensions went from 40 000 a
year in 1965
to over 1.6 million in 1986.
however these were still seasonal
workers and the flow was still circular
with 86 percent of undocumented workers
returning home at the end of the season
in practical terms little had changed in
the mexican-american migration system
but in symbolic terms much had changed
for now the majority of migrants were
illegal
and thus by definition considered to be
criminals
and law breakers while the demand for
seasonal agricultural work
stayed the same what the government did
was criminalize its workers
reacting to this perceived change the us
government began pouring more
and more resources into the border
patrol from 1986 to 2010
the number of uniformed border patrol
officers increased 5.6 times
the agency's budget grew by a factor of
17
and hundreds of miles of walls and
fencing were constructed
around ports of entry none of the extra
border security did anything to stop
border crossings
during the 1970s and 80s the odds of a
migrant being
apprehended while crossing the border
was about one in three
as more resources were poured into the
border patrol migrants began crossing in
more and more remote parts of the border
and the odds of a migrant being
apprehended actually went down for a
while
the diversion of border crossings into
remote areas lowered the odds of
apprehension
but it also increased the risk of injury
and even death
for in addition to being less populated
and less patrolled
these desolate areas were also more
dangerous
between 1993 and 2010 the number of
deaths along the border skyrocketed
coyotes and other smugglers moved in to
capitalize on the new black market
and border crossing became much more
expensive
in the two decades after 1993 the cost
of hiring a coyote to cross the border
increased by a factor of 4.6 in real
terms
but the biggest impact of increased
border security was that for the first
time
in the history of mexican-american
migration the movement of migrants
stopped being circular
finding it increasingly difficult and
dangerous and expensive to move back and
forth across the border for seasonal
work
migrants began staying in america during
the off-seasons
as men stayed longer north of the border
they were increasingly joined by wives
and children transitioning from a
seasonal migrant flow to a permanently
settled population
in other words the effect of restrictive
immigration and border policies
was the creation of an undocumented
population removing the brazero program
made a traditional migratory system
illegal
building walls in the southern border
didn't keep people out but rather
trapped them in
since 2007 the number of undocumented
migrants in the united states
has actually declined not because of the
efforts of border patrol
but rather because of an unrelated shift
in mexican migration patterns
in the last 15 years more people have
moved from the u.s to mexico
than from mexico to the united states
this shift was started
by the 2008 recession but has been
continued by a change in mexico's age
demographics
people tend to migrate when they're
younger if they do not move before the
age of 30 they're very unlikely to move
at all
in the last 50 years mexico's fertility
rate has dropped from 7.2 children per
woman
to 2.1 children per woman and the median
age of the mexican population has gone
from 16.7
to 29.3 turning mexico into an aging
country
new undocumented immigrants in recent
years have come not from mexico
but from other countries today most
undocumented immigrants enter the united
states legally
they enter as tourists and overstay
their visas border security doesn't
affect them
and yet still to this day there are
calls to increase border patrol staffing
to build more barriers and to strengthen
our borders
why no matter which way you stand on the
issue
there are better ways to address
undocumented migration than a largely
symbolic
totally ineffective and extremely
expensive border wall
you